eric zamor says france is being ruined
by immigration islam and political
correctness and his message is seducing
far-right and conservative voters
although he's yet to declare his
candidacy for the french presidency
zamor is already soaring in opinion
polls a political outsider with a
conviction for inciting racial hatred
that some call francis donald trump
he is a guy who does business that's not
me i write books and articles so my life
is different to his but like boris
johnson he understood our error and that
the main problems that we face in the
west are immigration and
de-industrialization
zimmer is of algerian jewish heritage he
had a slot on a channel called c news
that helped fuel his popularity and he's
a regular on tv shows where his opinions
often cause controversy
the media frenzy around him is partly
because he is a public figure who
crosses the line as no one else has in
france's public sphere
since since september zamora has been
traveling the country to promote his
latest book on a tour that's become a de
facto campaign in bordeaux more than a
thousand people came to see him
for us zamor embodies hope for france we
have seen france deteriorating for a few
years but zimmer gives us hope for our
country
france is in rapid decline because of
mass immigration and he's the only
person who can stop it eric's a
supporters say he's the man to save
france his opponent saying he could
destroy it
nearby dozens of protesters gathered
[Music]
it's catastrophic france has always been
multicultural and i'm proud of it i grew
up here the friends that zamor paints is
not a reality it is a lie filled with
hate
zamor has upset some election
predictions for final round between
far-right party leader marine le pen and
president emmanuel macron how he would
fare if he does run would depend on
voters what's clear for now though is
zamor is already disrupting the race
natasha butler al jazeera bordeaux
france